bachelor in paradise is back in
production post scandal and bachelor
nation superfan Ashton Kutcher couldn't
be happier
oh man no no man I'm so happy paradise
is back Ashton stop by Wednesday's Good
Morning America to promote his new
Netflix show the ranch are we hunker
down and the actor couldn't contain his
excitement about the return of one of he
and wife Mila Kunis's favorite shows
this is like our greatest guilty
pleasure of all time like we sit down a
Monday night is like religion in our
house in fact I haven't watched this
week because I was here and she's there
and so we're saving it oh that's nice
because this is our thing I mean it's
like it's unbelievable this show Ashton
and Mila made a surprise appearance on
this season of The Bachelorette to help
Rachel Lindsey fine husband material in
a obstacle course
challenge I'm gonna make a bold
prediction at this point okay
I don't think Rachel's guy is in this
group
both our dedicated fans of bachelor
nation Ashton says the couple created a
game during dates on the ABC hit show we
turn the volume off and we like watch
the one on one day and then she does the
voice of the girl and I do the voice
they go that's a show it's literally
like I'm like are you gonna eat the
chicken no are you gonna eat the chicken
you ever notice they never eat on the
show
[Music]